GOOD AFTERNOON. MEMBERS. THE
SENATE WILL CALL TO ORDER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GILL. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ DALLY. DODD. DURAZZO.
EGGMAN GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE.
HURTADO JONES. LAIRD. LIMON.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO. SATO.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER.
WILK GOOD AFTERNOON. MEMBERS. WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM. COULD I ASK
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BE ON
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE RISE? CHAU. WE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER. THIS AFTERNOON BY
OUR CHAPLAIN, SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN. AFTER WHICH, PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
SISTER MICHELLE, THANK YOU. SO
WE CENTER OURSELVES IN THE
PRESENCE OF THE HOLY, MERCIFUL
AND HEALING GOD. TODAY, WE SHARE
IN THE LONGINGS OF LANGSTON
HUGHES'S POEM I DREAM A WORLD
AND I DREAM A WORLD WHERE ALL
FOR NO OTHER ONE WILL SCORN.
WHERE LOVE WILL BLESS THE EARTH
AND PEACE ITS PATHS ADORN. I
DREAM A WORLD WHERE ALL WILL
KNOW SWEET FREEDOM'S WAY. WHERE
GREED NO LONGER SAPS THE SOUL.
NOR AVARICE BLIGHTS OUR DAY A
WORLD I DREAM. WHERE BLACK OR
WHITE. WHATEVER RACE YOU BE.
WILL SHARE THE BOUNTIES OF THE
EARTH. AND EVERYONE IS FREE.
WHERE WRETCHEDNESS WILL HANG ITS
HEAD AND JOY LIKE A PEARL
ATTENDS THE NEEDS OF HUMANKIND.
AND OF SUCH I DREAM MY WORLD AND
LOVING GOD. MAY WE CONTINUE TO
WORK FOR SUCH A DREAM. AMEN
MEMBERS, PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA FOR WHICH IT STANDS. ONE
NATION UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE,
WITH LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SENATE. RULE 55 WILL BE
SUSPENDED TO ALLOW GUESTS ON THE
FLOOR FOR TODAY'S SESSION. AND I
SEE A FEW OF THEM HERE. WELCOME
TO THE SENATE. MEMBERS, WE ARE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR. PLEASE. LET'S GET
OUR ATTENTION HERE. WE'RE GOING
TO INTRODUCE OUR GOOD SENATOR
FROM NAPA, SENATOR DODD AT THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK. MEMBERS,
PLEASE GIVE HIM YOUR ATTENTION.
SENATOR DODD. WELL, MEMBERS AND
GUESTS, THANK YOU VERY, VERY
MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING ABLE TO BRING
MY FAMILY TO THE FLOOR THIS IS
THE ONLY DATE FOR THE REST OF
OUR TERM UNTIL SEPTEMBER 1ST
THAT WE CAN ALL MAKE IT. AND I'M
JUST SO PROUD THAT ALL 13 OF MY
GRANDCHILDREN, ALL FIVE OF MY
KIDS AND FOUR OF THEIR SPOUSES
ARE HERE WITH ME TODAY IN THE
CHAMBER. AND I KNOW NINE OF
THESE GRANDCHILDREN WERE BORN
WHILE WE WERE IN SESSION. AND I
THINK SOME PEOPLE WERE SAYING,
OH, THEY HAD THEIR THAT GOES
DODD AGAIN, BRAGGING ABOUT
HAVING ANOTHER GRANDCHILD
BROUGHT INTO THE WORLD. AND I
GOT TO COMPETE WITH MY FRIENDS
FROM BAKERSFIELD AND FROM ORANGE
COUNTY AND OTHER PARTS. BUT IT'S
BEEN REALLY FUN. THEY HAVEN'T
ALL BEEN UP HERE TO BE ABLE TO
MEET THESE ARE MY COLLEAGUES. I
LOVE THESE PEOPLE SO MUCH AND
IT'S JUST BEEN AN INCREDIBLE
PLEASURE OVER TEN YEARS TO BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH ALL THESE
SENATORS. AND WITH THAT, I AM
GOING TO NAME THEM ALL. FIRST OF
ALL, IT DOESN'T HAPPEN. NONE OF
THIS HAPPENS WITHOUT MARRYING MY
WIFE, MARY. AND WE'VE WEIGHED MY
SON JEFF, HIS WIFE KELLY, AND
THEN WE HAVE HALLE AND CASEY AND
THE NEW ONE, BETTY. EIGHT MONTHS
AGO, I INTRODUCED HER ON THE
FLOOR. AND THEN WE HAVE MY SON
BRIAN, HIS WIFE, OLIVIA, AND WE
HAVE EMMA, AND WE HAVE EVERETT,
AND WE HAVE ROSIE RIGHT THERE,
BUDDY. NICE JOB. OKAY, THEN
WE'RE MY DAUGHTER BRIDGET AND
HER HUSBAND, CALE. NOAH THEIR
SON CALE. I KNEW I WAS GOING TO
SCREW THIS UP. THEIR SON, THEIR
SON CALE AND THE HICKMAN GIRLS,
AS I CALL THEM. ELSIE, MARY AND
HEATHER. AND THEN WE HAVE GEORGE
AND HER HUSBAND, ANDREW, AND WE
HAVE WILLIAM, WILLIAM. WE CALL
HIM LIAM AND JOSIE. RIGHT HERE.
AND THEN WE HAVE MY SON BOBBY.
WHERE ARE YOU? BOBBY AND HIS
SON, ELDON. THAT'S IT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. GETTING THE PICTURE,
GUYS. GET THE PICTURE. WE'RE
GOING TO GO. WELCOME TO THE
ENTIRE DODD FAMILY. TURN AROUND.
NÓ EYES. YES. WE GOT THE HOLIDAY
PICTURE HAPPENING RIGHT HERE,
BABY.
ALL RIGHT. WOW.
WELL, THAT WAS A LOT OF VOTES.
NO WONDER SENATOR DODD GOT
ELECTED. ALL RIGHT. WE WANT TO
NEXT INTRODUCE SENATOR STERN AT
THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK.
SENATOR STERN, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AS THE LONE
PORTUGUESE-AMERICAN HERE, MAYBE
SOME OF YOU DIDN'T REALIZE THAT.
THAT'S HALF MY FAMILY. YES. THE
MATTOS FAMILY. ALL THE WAY BACK
TO HAYWARD IN THE 1800S, AND AN
INTERESTING HIDDEN HISTORY OF MY
OWN THAT LEADS ALL THE WAY BACK
TO THE AZORES AS, JEWS WHO WERE
IN FACT HIDDEN AND ESCAPED
DURING THE INQUISITION, SOMEHOW
MADE IT THROUGH BRAZIL AND ALL
THE WAY UP TO THIS COUNTRY. I'M
SO PROUD TO HAVE THE HONOR TODAY
, TO INTRODUCE TO US THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE AZORES, WHICH
IS A SEMI-AUTONOMOUS REGION NOT
UNLIKE CALIFORNIA OF PORTUGAL,
MR. ARTUR LIMA, HE'S BACK HERE
IN CALIFORNIA, IN PART TO
CELEBRATE HIS JUNE, WHICH IS
PORTUGUESE HERITAGE, PORTUGUESE
HERITAGE MONTH AND TO CONTINUE
TO FOSTER RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THE AZORES AND CALIFORNIA. WE
SENT A DELEGATION THERE A FEW
YEARS BACK, AND THEY HAVE
TREMENDOUS RESOURCES, WHETHER IT
COMES TO CLIMATE RESEARCH AND
OCEANOGRAPHIC RESEARCH,
RENEWABLE ENERGY WORK, WORK IN
AGRICULTURE, WE'RE TREMENDOUSLY
GRATEFUL THAT THEY'VE COME TO
CALIFORNIA, THROUGH QUITE A SAGA
OF TRAVEL. BUT HE'S MADE IT, AND
HE'S ON THE FLOOR HERE WITH MR.
DENNIS BORGES, PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA PORTUGUESE AMERICAN
COALITION. AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE A GROUP OF OUR
PORTUGUESE CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
HERE IN THE CAPITOL, HERE TO
JOIN THE VICE PRESIDENT. SO
MEMBERS, PLEASE GIVE A WARM
SENATE WELCOME HERE TO VICE
PRESIDENT LIMA AND THE MEMBERS
OF THE PORTUGUESE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
MEMBERS. WE HAVE ANOTHER SPECIAL
GUEST HERE ON OUR SENATE FLOOR.
WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO OUR
ESTEEMED SENATOR FROM FULLERTON.
SENATOR NEWMAN, FOR PURPOSES OF
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'M JOINED TODAY BY
ONE OF MY MOST INFLUENTIAL
CONSTITUENTS, WHO TOOK TIME OUT
OF HER BUSY SCHEDULE TO SPEND
SOME TIME WITH US. SHE IS A
FUTURE TEACHER, MARINE
BIOLOGIST, DOG TRAINER, CAKE
DECORATOR, ARCHITECT, OLYMPIC
SWIMMER, FIGURE SKATER, ICE
HOCKEY PLAYER AND PROFESSIONAL
SKIER, WITH THAT, PLEASE GIVE A
WARM CALIFORNIA WELCOME TO MISS
CECILY NEWMAN. WELCOME. RIGHT.
THE CECILY NEWMAN WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
WE'D LIKE TO NOW TURN TO OUR
GOOD SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES,
SENATOR DURAZO, FOR PURPOSES OF
INTRODUCTION, SENATOR DURAZO,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES AND GUESTS, WE ARE
JOINED BY SPECIAL GUESTS. MR.
ANTHONY, RIGHT, AND HIS FAMILY,
INCLUDING HIS WIFE, JESSICA AND
SON, JEFFERSON. ARE THEY HERE?
WE ARE HERE TO THANK MR. RIGHT
FOR HIS TREMENDOUS CONTRIBUTIONS
TOWARDS EXPANDING AND PRESERVING
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS. HE
SERVED AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA FOR
22 YEARS. DURING HIS TENURE,
HEALTH ACCESS HAS SERVED AS A
CRITICAL ADVOCACY GROUP IN
HELPING SECURE SEVERAL HEALTH
CARE REFORM AS PATIENT
PROTECTIONS, INVESTMENTS IN
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE, COST
CONTAINMENT AND COVERAGE
EXPANSION. IN THESE EFFORTS, MR.
RIGHT HAS REMAINED A RELENTLESS
CONSUMER ADVOCATE, INCLUSIVE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER, AND A PURE
PUBLIC SERVANT WHO HAS BEEN
GUIDED BY THE NORTH STAR THAT
ALL CALIFORNIA FANS, REGARDLESS
OF BACKGROUND OR ANY OTHER
ASPECT IN LIVES, HAVE ACCESS TO
A FUNDAMENTAL, BASIC HUMAN RIGHT
AND HIGHER QUALITY OF LIFE.
FUNDAMENTAL Kò HE BELIEVES IN
FIGHTS TO REALIZE AN EQUITABLE,
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM FOR ALL PEOPLE ON A
POINT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE, I
WANT TO THANK ANTHONY FOR HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE HEALTH FOR
ALL CAMPAIGN, WHERE MY OFFICE
PARTNERED WITH HIM, AND A HUGE
COALITION TO EXPAND MEDI-CAL
ACCESS TO INCOME ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS, REGARDLESS OF
STATUS. THIS AMBITIOUS,
TRAILBLAZING EFFORT WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN REALIZED WITHOUT THE
DEDICATION AND THE WORK THAT MR.
RIGHT PROVIDED. IT IS
BITTERSWEET THAT WE ARE
ACKNOWLEDGING MR. RIGHT HERE
BECAUSE AFTER 22 YEARS, HE HAS
BEEN CALLED TO SERVE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C, WHERE HE WILL
CONTINUE HIS PROFESSIONAL LIFE'S
WORK FIGHTING FOR HEALTH CARE
ACCESS TO ALL FAMILIES AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL. AS THE INCOMING
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF FAMILIES
USA, IT'S A TREMENDOUS LOSS TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, BUT I
HOPE YOU ALL JOIN ME IN THANKING
MR. RIGHT FOR THESE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO SO MANY IN
CALIFORNIA. WISH HIM AND HIS
FAMILY ALL THE BEST ON THEIR NEW
ENDEAVORS IN THE NATION'S
CAPITAL. FELICIDADES ANTHONY.
BUENA SUERTE.
WE HAVE ANOTHER SENATOR THAT
WANTS TO BE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
INTRODUCTION. SIR. RIGHT. HANG
ON ONE SECOND. WE WANT TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR HURTADO. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I ALSO RISE
IN RECOGNITION OF MR. ANTHONY.
RIGHT, FOR MANY OF YOU THAT
DON'T KNOW THIS, BUT LONG BEFORE
I WAS, A LITTLE BEFORE I WAS
STATE SENATOR, BACK IN 2018, I
USED TO HAVE THE HONOR OF
WORKING FOR ANTHONY, RIGHT, WITH
HEALTH ACCESS. AND YOU KNOW, IF
YOU ASK SOMEONE WHAT MAKES A
GREAT LEADER, I WOULD SAY THAT
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE QUALITIES
IS BEING A GOOD LISTENER. AND I
HAVE TO SAY THAT ANTHONY WAS
THAT AND MUCH MORE, HE WAS A
GOOD LISTENER, ALWAYS AVAILABLE
TO ANYONE AND EVERYONE THAT WAS
PART OF HIS TEAM. AND HE WAS,
YOU KNOW, WORKING AND ORGANIZING
STATEWIDE, I KNOW THAT WHEN I
CAME ON BOARD, IT WAS THE FIRST,
POSITION IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
SO THERE WAS A LOT OF LEARNING
THAT OCCURRED. BUT HE WAS
EXTREMELY OPEN TO IT. HE WAS
ABOUT PROVIDING ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE AND IMPROVING THE LIVES OF
PEOPLE, NOT JUST IN MY CENTRAL
VALLEY, BUT BEYOND. AND SO HE
WAS A GREAT LISTENER, A GREAT
ADVOCATE, AND I WISH YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY THE BEST, AND WE
WILL MISS YOU. BUT I KNOW THAT
YOU'LL ALWAYS BE AROUND. THANK
YOU, SENATOR HURTADO. MR.
WRIGHT, CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
MANY YEARS OF FINE SERVICE TO
OUR STATE. AND WE WISH YOU WELL
WITH YOUR FUTURE ENDEAVORS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
MEMBERS, WE HAVE ONE MORE,
SPECIAL INTRODUCTION OF OUR
FORMER SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY.
WE'RE GOING TO DEFER THAT FOR A
FEW MINUTES UNTIL HIS ARRIVAL.
WE'LL MOVE AHEAD WITH OUR
AGENDA. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOVING
NEXT TO MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. WITHOUT OBJECTION, THE
SENATE JOURNAL FOR JUNE 17TH,
2024 THROUGH JUNE 20TH, 2024
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY
THE MINUTE CLERK. THERE ARE FOUR
AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK. THEY'LL
BE DEEMED ADOPTED. BY THE NEXT.
RECOGNIZE OUR MAJORITY LEADER,
SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDING OFFICER, I MOVE JOINT
RULE 62 A TO BE WAIVED FOR THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO MEET AND
HEAR BILLS WITHOUT SUFFICIENT
NOTICE IN THE SENATE DAILY FILE
ONE. HOUSING COMMITTEE TO HEAR
AB 2579 TODAY, JUNE 24TH, 2024
TWO AG COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB 2113
TOMORROW, JUNE 25TH THIRD LOCAL
GOVT TO HEAR AC TEN AND AB 2813
ON WEDNESDAY, JUNE 26TH. AN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO HEAR
THE BILLS LISTED AS ABOVE AS
WELL AC EIGHT, AB 628, AB 2288,
AB 2927 AND AB 1935. THANK YOU.
SENATOR GONZALEZ HAS MOVED TO
WAIVE RULE 62, A SENATOR CIERTO.
WE OBJECT TO THESE LAST MINUTE
RULE WAIVERS AND KINDLY ASKED
FOR A NO VOTE. ALL RIGHT. SO WE
WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL. VOTE ON
THIS. SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP,
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALAN ALVARADO. GIL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI. NO DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO.
AYE JONES. LAIRD. AYE. LEMON
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MIN. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. NO.
NILO NO. OCHOA. BORG. NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO.
NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG.
AYE WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN JONES. MIN. WILK. ON A VOTE
OF 30 IN FAVOR, SIX AGAINST. THE
MOTION IS ADOPTED. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDING OFFICER, I MOVE ALL
MEASURES REPORTED BY THE BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE AND
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE ON
WEDNESDAY, JUNE 26TH, 2024, TO
BE GIVEN A SECOND READING UPON
BEING REPORTED AND ORDERED TO
THE THIRD READING. SENATOR
GONZALEZ HAS MADE SUCH A MOTION.
SENATOR CIERTO. YES, WE OBJECT
TO THESE AS WELL, THESE RULE
WAIVERS AS WELL, AND SIMPLY ASK
FOR A NO VOTE. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE PREVIOUS
VOTE ROLL CALL VOTE ANY
OBJECTION. ALL RIGHT. AYES 30
NOES SIX. THAT MOTION IS ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. THE SECOND READING
FILE. THE CLERK PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 3220 WITH
AMENDMENTS 1818, WITH AMENDMENTS
2357, WITH AMENDMENTS 1984, WITH
AMENDMENTS 2062, WITH AMENDMENTS
2993. WITH AMENDMENTS 2611, WITH
AMENDMENTS. SECOND READING FILE
WILL BE DEEMED COMPLETED. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. FIRST UP IS FILE
ITEM 21. SENATOR GROVE IS
PRESENTING SENATOR GROVE, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES TODAY FILE
ITEM 21 IS A CONFIRMATION OF
JARED PATTON AS THE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
PRIOR TO HIS APPOINTMENT, HE WAS
SERVED AS THE REGIONAL DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS. HE HAS A
HEART AND A PASSION FOR YOUTH,
AND WHAT THE CORPS ACTUALLY DOES
TO HELP AND BENEFIT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON JUNE 5TH
ON A50 VOTE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR GROVE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS NOMINATION, ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI I. DODD. AYE DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER I. AYE.
GONZALEZ I. GROVE AYE. HURTADO
I. JONES. LAIRD AYE. LEMON AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR I MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. AYE.
NILO. AYE. OCHOA. BORG AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE. UMMER.
AYE WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
SENATOR GROVE MOVES A CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 23, SENATOR GROVE. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES,
FILE ITEM 23 IS A CONFIRMATION
OF CHIKA SUNDQUIST FOR
APPOINTMENT TO THE REAL ESTATE
COMMISSIONER FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF REAL ESTATE. MISS SUNDQUIST
HAS HAD NEARLY TWO DECADES OF A
CAREER IN THE DEPARTMENT. MOST
RECENTLY SERVING AS THE DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER OF ENFORCEMENT. SHE
WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE 12TH ON A50
VOTE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
GROVE. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
NOMINATION, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS NOMINATION?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE. OCHOA.
BOG AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK SENATOR GROVE
MOVES A CALL. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 25.
SENATOR GROVE PRESENTING. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES,
FILE ITEM 25 IS A CONFIRMATION
OF THE FOLLOWING APPOINTEES
RAJESH PATEL, FRANK RAMIREZ AND
PETER SANTILLAN FOR THE BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION. BRENDA
DAVIS FOR THE REAPPOINTMENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
BOARD, AND REBECCA FOSTER AND
DAVE RAND FOR REAPPOINTMENT TO
THE HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
CORPORATION BOARD OF DIRECTORS,
ALL THESE APPOINTEES WERE
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON A50 VOTE ON JULY OR EXCUSE
ME, JUNE 12TH. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR GROVE, ANY DISCUSSION ON
THESE NOMINATIONS, ANY
DISCUSSION ON THESE NOMINATIONS?
SEEING NONE, SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE A ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI. AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE JONES.
LAIRD. AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR I MEN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA BORG. AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. AYE. SKINNER. AYE
SMALL. THEY TURNED IT OFF FOR ME
. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE LAST
TIME, PLEASE. ALAN JONES. WILK
AYE. ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0, THE
NOMINATIONS ARE CONFIRMED. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALLS ON FILE ITEM 21.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN JONES, WILK
AYE. ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0, THE
NOMINATION IS CONFIRMED. WE'LL
LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM 23.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN. EGGMAN
AYE. JONES MINH. AYE. WILK AYE.
ON A VOTE OF 38 TO 0, THE
NOMINEE IS CONFIRMED. MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO
SENATE. THIRD READING. WE HAVE
FIVE MEASURES COMING BEFORE THE.
THE BODY HERE THIS AFTERNOON.
FIVE MEASURES. WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM 39.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 132 BY
SENATOR CIERTO RELATIVE TO HIRE
VETERAN DAY SENATOR CIERTO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SCR 132 EACH YEAR,
200,000 SERVICE MEMBERS LEAVE
THE ARMED SERVICES AND BECOME
VETERANS. AND THAT TRANSITION
FROM MILITARY TO CIVILIAN WORK
HAS MANY CHALLENGES. CALIFORNIA
IS HOME TO NEARLY 2 MILLION
VETERANS AND OUR STATE'S
HOMELESS VETERAN POPULATION
MAKES UP ABOUT 31% OF THE ENTIRE
NATION'S HOMELESS POPULATION.
VETERANS 35 TO 64 YEARS OF AGE
ARE CONSISTENTLY AT HIGHER
LEVELS OF UNEMPLOYMENT IN
CALIFORNIA. FINDING AND
COMPETING FOR CIVILIAN POSITIONS
CAN BE VERY DIFFICULT. A VERY
DIFFICULT TRANSITION FOR
VETERANS, BUT THEY BRING
COMPETITIVE SKILLS AND CORE
VALUES LIKE LOYALTY, HARD WORK,
INTEGRITY AND RESPECT. VETERANS
ARE ALSO A GREAT ASSET IN THE
WORKPLACE, MANY OF THEM
TECHNICAL EXPERTS IN THEIR FIELD
AND POSSESS LEADERSHIP AND TEAM
EXPERIENCE THAT PROVES
INVALUABLE UPON REENTRY INTO THE
CIVILIAN WORKFORCE IN 2021,
NEARLY 38% OF CALIFORNIA'S
VETERANS HELD A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE OR HIGHER. AND THAT'S NOT
COUNTING ALL THOSE THAT HOLD
VOCATIONAL CERTIFICATES AND
DIPLOMAS. ADDING TO OUR
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES,
VOCATIONAL TRADE WORKFORCES AND
BEYOND. NATIONAL HIRE A VETERAN
DAY WAS CREATED IN 2017 AS A
CALL TO ACTION FOR COMPANIES TO
ENCOURAGE VETERAN JOB APPLICANTS
. SCR 132 ESTABLISHES JULY 25TH,
2020 FOR IS HIRE A VETERAN DAY
IN CALIFORNIA TO REMIND
EMPLOYERS THAT AMERICANS
VETERANS ARE READY, ABLE AND
WILLING TO WORK HIRE OUR VETERAN
DAY HONORS VETERANS WHO HAVE
SACRIFICED FOR THE UNITED STATES
AND REMINDS JOB SEEKERS AND JOB
CREATORS ABOUT THE VALUE OF
HIRING A VETERAN IN CALIFORNIA
MEMBERS, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR CIERTO. ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS RESOLUTION? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE, THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AYES 38 NÓ
ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 44. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION 17 BY
SENATOR ALAN, RELATIVE TO THE LÀ
AND NATIONAL MONUMENT,
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
ALAN SENATOR PADILLA. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, ON
BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA MONICA, I RISE TO PRESENT
SJR 17, A RESOLUTION URGING THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO
ESTABLISH NATIONAL MONUMENTS TO
PERMANENTLY PROTECT THE LÀ AND
KANSEN LANDS. THE PROPOSED
MONUMENTS INCLUDE THE PIT RIVER
TRIBES, ANCESTRAL HOMELANDS IN
SANTEETLAH AND MEDICINE LAKE
HIGHLANDS, AS WELL AS THE
CULTURAL HOMELANDS OF THE FORT
YUMA, QUECHAN INDIAN TRIBE. THE
PERMANENT PROTECTION OF THESE
REGIONS WILL REPRESENT HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF ACRES OF
ADDITIONAL CONSERVATION THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO MEETING OUR 30 BY 30
GOALS AND PROTECTING OUR
ENDANGERED BIODIVERSITY, IN
ADDITION TO IRREPLACEABLE PLANT
AND ANIMAL LIFE, THESE LANDS
HOUSED THE INDELIBLE MARKS THE
PHYSICAL, CULTURAL AND SPIRITUAL
HISTORY OF OUR STATES,
INDIGENOUS POPULATIONS. THE
TRIBAL LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE
OF LAND CONSERVATION ACROSS
CALIFORNIA HAS SET AN EXAMPLE
FOR THE STATE GOVERNMENT, AS
WELL AS OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
TAKEN IMPORTANT STEPS TOWARD
CONSERVATION, SUCH AS THE RECENT
EXPANSION OF THE SAN GABRIEL
MOUNTAINS AND BERRYESSA SNOW
MOUNTAIN NATIONAL MONUMENTS. BUT
WE MUST KEEP MAKING PROGRESS.
MEMBERS, PLEASE JOIN ME IN
URGING THE ADMINISTRATION TO
CONTINUE THE THIS IMPORTANT WORK
OF CONSERVATION, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR PADILLA
. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
RESOLUTION? THIS COULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
. ALL RIGHT. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LEMON
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MINH. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN.
NILO OCHOA. BOGH AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN
DAWLEY. GROVE. AYE. JONES
NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE. WILK. AYE
. ON A VOTE OF 37 TO 0. THE
MOTION IS ADOPTED. EXCUSE ME.
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 45.
SENATE BILL 1481 BY SENATOR
CABALLERO. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 1481 BY SENATOR
CABALLERO. AN ACT RELATING TO
THE PAYMENT OF CLAIMS AGAINST
THE STATE, MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFOR, AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
CABALLERO, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. SB 1481 IS THE SECOND
OF TWO BILLS CARRIED BY THE
CHAIR CHAIRS OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO
PROVIDE PAYMENT AUTHORITY FOR
LEGAL CLAIMS APPROVED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THIS
URGENCY MEASURE APPROPRIATES
$19.3 MILLION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND FOR THE PAYMENT OF CLAIMS
AGAINST THE STATE, ARISING FROM
FIVE SPECIFIED CASES AS I AS
IDENTIFIED IN APPROVED
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS. THESE
CLAIMS ARE BINDING STATE
OBLIGATIONS AND FAILURE TO
APPROVE PAYMENT FOR THESE CLAIMS
WOULD RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
LITIGATION IN STATE COURTS
COSTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR CABALLERO. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SEEING NONE, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE SPEER.
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON. AYE MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MINH. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. BOGUE
BADHIYA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE CIERTO.
SKINNER. AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
AYE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE DALY. GROVE. JONES NGUYEN.
NILO. OCHOA BOGUE. SUGIARTO
THAT'S A VOTE OF 32 TO 0 ON THE
URGENCY. 32 TO 0 ON THE MEASURE.
MEMBERS, WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
BUT FIRST, ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
BRADFORD, LET ME INTRODUCE SOME
SPECIAL GUESTS THAT ARE HERE IN
THE CHAMBER. I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
UP IN THE GALLERY. I BELIEVE
FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUSTY
ARIAS AND GARY CONDIT WHO ARE UP
THERE. WE WELCOME YOU HERE ON
THE FLOOR. HERE ON THE FLOOR, WE
HAVE WITH US OUR CONGRESSMAN JIM
COSTA, FORMER OUR ASSEMBLY
SPEAKER, AND SENATOR ROBERT
HERTZBERG, FORMER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PAUL HORCHER, FORMER
SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND ATTORNEY
GENERAL. THE ESTEEMED BILL
LOCKYER, FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
SONNY MOJGANI, AND FORMER STATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, SENATOR AND
STATE SUPERINTENDENT JACK
O'CONNELL. WELCOME TO THE
SENATE. MEMBERS. AND WE WILL NOW
TURN TO OUR GOOD SENATOR
BRADFORD AT THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK FOR PURPOSES OF
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND IT'S TRULY MY
DISTINCT HONOR TO INTRODUCE
SOMEONE WHO REALLY NEEDS NO
INTRODUCTION, WHOSE REPUTATION
PRECEDES HIMSELF AND DIVIDUAL,
WHO EMBODIES STATESMANSHIP,
LEADER SHIP COLLABORATION,
BIPARTISAN LEADERSHIP HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, A
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS KNOWN FOR HIS
ORATORIO KHÓ SPLENDOR AND HIS
SARTORIAL EXCELLENCE. NONE OTHER
THAN SPEAKER EMERITUS WILLIE
LOUIS BROWN JR FOR THE VERY
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN SPEAKER
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
AND THE. FIRST AFRICAN-AMERICAN
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO. HE IS REFERRED TO AS
THE KING KONG OF CALIFORNIA.
POLITICS. MR. BROWN IS CONTINUES
TO HAVE A LONG AND LEGENDARY
CAREER. MR. BROWN WAS BORN IN
MINEOLA, TEXAS. A VERY HUMBLE
BEGINNINGS, AND HE LEARNED HIS
TREMENDOUS WORK ETHIC FROM HIS
GRANDMOTHER. HIS FIRST JOB AS A
YOUNG BOY WAS SHINING SHOES IN A
WHITE ONLY BARBER SHOP. HE LATER
WENT ON TO WORK AS A JANITOR, A
FRY COOK, AND A FIELD HAND, AND
UPON GRADUATING FROM HIGH
SCHOOL, HE DECIDED TO MOVE TO
CALIFORNIA TO SAN FRANCISCO TO
LOOK FOR A BETTER OPPORTUNITY.
IT WAS HIS INTENTIONS TO GO TO
STANFORD, BUT THEY DIDN'T ACCEPT
HIM IN STANFORD. BUT LUCKY FOR
MR. BROWN, THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
WAS ON THE INTERVIEWING PANEL
STRONGLY RECOMMENDED HIM FOR SAN
FRANCISCO STATE, WHERE HE WENT
ON TO GRADUATE THERE AND
ESTABLISH HIMSELF ON CAMPUS
ACTIVITIES. AND THEN WENT ON TO
GET A LAW DEGREE. AND AS YOU
TALK TO MR. BROWN, HIS
INTENTIONS NEVER WAS TO BE A
LAWYER. IT WAS TO BE A MATH
TEACHER. AND ONE OF THE REASONS
HE ENROLLED IN LAW SCHOOL WAS TO
AVOID THE DRAFT. AND HE
GRADUATED FROM HASTINGS LAW
SCHOOL AND QUICKLY OPENED A LAW
PRACTICE. AND HE REPRESENTED
PIMPS, PROSTITUTES AND OTHER
CLIENTS THAT MORE PROMINENT LAW
LAW FIRMS DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH. IT WAS
THROUGH THIS ACTIVITY THAT HE
GARNERED HIS STRONG PASSION FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS, EQUALITY, AND
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE, THE
UNDERREPRESENTED AND UNDERDOGS,
HAD A VOICE. HE WAS. THEN HE
SOUGHT ELECTED OFFICIAL OFFICE,
I SHOULD SAY. AND IN 1962, HE
WAS UNSUCCESSFUL, BUT A PASTOR
RAISED MONEY FOR HIM, ALL OF A
WHOPPING $700 FOR HIS CAMPAIGN
AND THE CHURCH PASSING THE HAT.
I MEAN, THAT WAS A LOT BACK THEN
AND, LATER RAN TWO YEARS LATER
AND WAS SUCCESSFULLY ELECTED TO
THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY IN 1964.
AND HIS TENURE, AS WE ALL KNOW,
SPANNED SEVEN GOVERNORS, FROM
GOVERNOR PETE, PAT BROWN TO
GOVERNOR ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER.
MR. BROWN, AS WE ALL KNOW, HOLDS
THE RECORD FOR THE LONGEST
SERVING SPEAKER IN THE STATE
HISTORY. AND UNDER CURRENT TERM
LIMITS, WE KNOW THAT WILL NEVER
BE BROKE AND FORTUNATELY AND
UNFORTUNATELY, HE'S THE REASON
WHY WE HAVE TERM LIMITS TODAY.
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO
BEAT WILLIE BROWN. SO THEY CHOSE
TO PASS TERM LIMITS AND END
THEIR OWN CAREERS JUST TO, YOU
KNOW, DIMINISH WHAT HE WAS DOING
DURING HIS TENURE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. MR. BROWN LEFT HIS
MARK ON EVERY ASPECT OF PUBLIC
POLICY IMPACTING CALIFORNIA. HIS
LEADERSHIP RESULTED IN
LEGISLATION THAT BANNED SEMI
AUTOMATIC WEAPONS, GAINED STATE
DIVESTMENT FROM SOUTH AFRICA,
ENDED THE CRIMINALIZATION OF
HOMOSEXUALITY, AND CREATED
GREATER STABILITY IN OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM THROUGH THE
SCHOOL FINANCE REFORM. HE ALSO
HELPED ESTABLISH THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS AND ALL THE OTHER
ETHNIC CAUCUSES THAT EXIST TODAY
IN THE LEGISLATURE. DUE TO HIS
TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP AND 30
YEARS AFTER LEAVING THE
ASSEMBLY, HIS IMPACT IS STILL
FELT AND SEEN TODAY. BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF STAFF PEOPLE WHO
STILL WORK IN THIS BUILDING, OR
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE ACROSS THE STREET AS
LOBBYISTS, AS CONSULTANTS OR
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
INDIVIDUALS, AND I CAN GO ON AND
ON AND ON ABOUT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND WHAT THEY DO
AND, AND, AND THE IMPACT. MR.
BROWN HAD ON THEIR CAREERS
FOLLOWING HIS ROLE AS SPEAKER OF
THE ASSEMBLY, MR. BROWN
CONTINUED HIS GROUNDBREAKING
CAREER IN PUBLIC SERVICE AS
BECOMING THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO. AS MAYOR, HE LED
THE EFFORT TO REBUILD
CALIFORNIA'S BUSIEST TRANSIT
SYSTEM, PIONEERED THE USE OF
BOND MEASURES TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, AND CREATED
A MODEL JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THESE ACCOMPLISHMENTS ARE JUST A
BRIEF GLIMPSE OF THE VARIETY AND
SCOPE OF A FORWARD THINKING
IDEAS THAT WERE REALIZED UNDER
HIS LEADERSHIP. TODAY, THE
ASSEMBLY HAS DECLARED TODAY,
WILLIE BROWN DAY IN RECOGNITION
OF HIS MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS, AS
WELL AS MR. BROWN'S UNRELATED,
UNRELENTING DEDICATION TO A
BETTER CALIFORNIA FOR ALL.
EARLIER TODAY, THERE WAS A
RECEPTION HERE IN THE CAPITOL,
AND IT WAS ATTENDED BY THE WHO'S
WHO OF FORMER ELECTED OFFICIALS,
STAFFERS, YOU NAME IT, AS MANY
ARE ON THE FLOOR TODAY. AND I
DON'T KNOW ANYONE ELSE WHO COULD
PROBABLY GATHER THAT MANY
CURRENT OR FORMER MEMBERS TO PAY
TRIBUTE TO AN INDIVIDUAL SUCH AS
MR. BROWN, AND I WAS HONORED TO
MEET MR. BROWN IN 1988 AS A
YOUNG, ASPIRING INDIVIDUAL
WANTING TO GET INVOLVED IN
POLITICS, AND IT WAS THROUGH HIS
FORMER STAFF, MY LATE FRAT
BROTHER DARNELL COOLEY, WHO
INTRODUCED ME TO MR. BROWN
DURING A BAY PARTY CONVENTION
AND I AND I WON'T SAY A
FRIENDSHIP WAS FORMED, BUT A
MUTUAL RESPECT. AND AS AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS BORN IN
TEXAS, I WAS EMBARRASSED TO TELL
FOLKS I WAS BORN IN TEXAS
BECAUSE TEXAS REPRESENTED SO
MANY NEGATIVE THINGS SLAVERY,
RACISM. BUT NOT UNTIL I MET MR.
BROWN AND SAW HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. AND HE WAS FROM
MINEOLA, TEXAS, AND I DIDN'T
EVEN KNOW WHERE THE HELL THAT
WAS. BUT IT MADE ME PROUD TO SAY
I TOO, WAS FROM TEXAS, AND I'VE
CARRIED THAT BADGE OF HONOR EVER
SINCE I'VE MET MR. BROWN AND I'M
HONORED TO NOW CALL HIM A
MENTOR. AND I WAS DEEPLY MOVED
WHEN I GOT ELECTED IN A SPECIAL
ELECTION IN OH NINE. AND I CAME
IN BY MYSELF AND MY STAFF TOLD
ME, THEY SAID, MR. BROWN WANTS
TO MEET YOU FOR LUNCH IN SAN
FRANCISCO, AND I DIDN'T BELIEVE
IT. AND BUT IT WAS TRUE. I
QUICKLY GOT IN THE CAR AND DROVE
TO THE FOUR SEASONS, WHERE WE
HAD LUNCH THAT DAY, AND I
GLEANED SO MUCH FROM MR. BROWN
AND HE CLEARLY TOLD ME, HE SAYS,
BRADFORD, THIS BUSINESS IS NOT
HOW SMART YOU ARE. IT'S ABOUT
RELATIONSHIPS. IT'S ABOUT
KNOWING YOUR COLLEAGUES, KNOWING
THE ISSUES. AND I'VE HEARD SOME
OF THE BEST. WILLIE BROWN
STORIES, NOT FROM DEMOCRATS, BUT
FROM REPUBLICANS LIKE THE LATE
BILL DUPLISSEA, WHO LOVED WILLIE
BROWN. BUILD A POLICY, WAS A ONE
TERM ASSEMBLYMAN, AND WILLIE
BROWN TOOK HIM OUT. BUT THEY
WERE STILL FRIENDSHIP FRIENDS
UNTIL THE DAY HE DIED. SO THIS
BUSINESS IS ABOUT RELATIONSHIPS,
FOLKS, AND MR. BROWN EPITOMIZES
THAT BETTER THAN NOBODY ELSE.
THAT I KNOW. AND MY 20 PLUS
YEARS OF BEING AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL, AND I'M HONORED TO
CALL HIM A MENTOR. SO PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING SPEAKER
EMERITUS WILLIE LEWIS BROWN TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
SPEAKER, THANK YOU, SENATOR
BRADFORD. WE HAVE MICROPHONES UP
FROM SOME OTHER COLLEAGUES WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE HEARD ON THIS,
ACCOMPLISHMENT. WE'LL START
FIRST WITH OUR FORMER PRO TEM
SENATOR ATKINS, FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR WIENER, FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR UMBERG. SENATOR ATKINS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. WELL,
IT'S HARD TO ADD TO WHAT THE
SENATOR FROM GARDENA HAS SAID,
AND I THINK YOU COVERED A LOT OF
BASES THERE, RESPECTFULLY. BUT I
WANT TO RISE TO SAY THANK YOU,
AS A FORMER SPEAKER FOR, IT'S
QUITE AN HONOR TO EVEN BE IN
YOUR PRESENCE. I REMEMBER WHEN I
WAS SWORN IN, YOU WERE THERE. I
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF THE ADVICE
OVER THE YEARS, JOHN PEREZ WAS
MY SPEAKER. WE ALL KNOW THESE
THINGS, BUT MR. BROWN IS THE
SPEAKER. AND SO HIS DESK REMAINS
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR, ONE OF
ONLY ONE OTHER PERSON THAT HAS A
DESK THAT IS NOT OCCUPIED ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. AND I JUST WANT
TO SAY YOU ARE ICONIC, I FELT
THE WELCOME WHEN I WOULD ARRIVE,
EITHER AS SPEAKER OR PRO TEM IN
SAN FRANCISCO. ALWAYS AN
INVITATION TO JOIN YOU FOR LUNCH
OR COFFEE. AND I APPRECIATE SO
MUCH YOUR ADVICE AND THOUGHTS,
PARTICULARLY THE HUMOROUS ONES.
OVER THE YEARS. AND I JUST RISE
TO SAY THANK YOU, SIR, AND IT'S
AN HONOR TO HAVE YOU ON OUR
SENATE FLOOR TODAY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ATKINS. WE WILL NEXT
RECOGNIZE THE SENATOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO, FOLLOWED BY THE
SENATOR FROM FULLERTON, FOLLOWED
BY THE SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES.
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SO I THINK A LOT OF
TIMES WHEN SPEAKER BROWN COMES,
PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT HIS ROLE AS
SPEAKER AND THAT UNIQUE ROLE
THAT HE PLAYED LEADING THIS
INSTITUTION FOR, FOR SO MANY
YEARS, PEOPLE DON'T ALWAYS KNOW
AS MUCH ABOUT, THE ABSOLUTE
GIANT THAT WILLIE BROWN IS IN
SAN FRANCISCO, TO THIS DAY. AND
WHEN YOU REPRESENT SAN FRANCISCO
AND THE LEGISLATURE, YOU ARE
DOING SO IN THE SHADOW OF WILLIE
BROWN, BECAUSE FOR SO MANY
YEARS, HE DELIVERED FOR SAN
FRANCISCO. AND THAT PUTS A LOT
OF WEIGHT ON THOSE OF US WHO
COME AFTER. AND SO, MR. SPEAKER,
I'LL SAY, MR. MAYOR, BECAUSE YOU
ARE MY MAYOR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR EVERYTHING THAT YOU HAVE
DONE, AND HE ALSO, MAYOR BROWN
IS EVERYWHERE, EVERYWHERE ALL
THESE YEARS AFTER BEING MAYOR.
HE IS EVERYWHERE. THE ENERGY
LEVEL. I JUST IT'S
EXTRAORDINARY, HE ALSO, I SEEK
OUT HIS ADVICE FROM TIME TO TIME
WHEN I'M REALLY IN TROUBLE, AND
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO, HE
SOMETIMES GIVES ME UNSOLICITED
ADVICE, LIKE WHEN I. YOU MAY
RECALL, WAS PURSUING THE 4 A.M.
AFTER HOURS BILL EXTENDING,
LIQUOR SERVICE TO 4 A.M, AND I,
WE WERE FIGHTING THAT FIGHT, AND
I RUN INTO, MAYOR BROWN AT AN
EVENT, AND HE SAYS, WIENER, YOUR
MISTAKE IS NOT STARTING. YOU
DIDN'T START OUT OF 24 HOURS AND
THEN NEGOTIATE DOWN TO 4 A.M. I
SAID, YOU KNOW WHAT? YOU'RE
PROBABLY RIGHT, I ALSO JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT THAT WILLIE BROWN,
IN ADDITION TO THE INCREDIBLE
WORK HE DID UP HERE, HE WAS PART
OF A COMPLETE TRANSFORMATION OF
SAN FRANCISCO POLITICS WHEN HE
CAME INTO OFFICE, SAN FRANCISCO
WAS A LOT OF REPUBLICANS IN
CONTROL, VERY WHITE, VERY
STRAIGHT, VERY, VERY OLD SCHOOL.
AND AND WILLIE BROWN WAS PART OF
A GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO BROUGHT
SAN FRANCISCO INTO THE MODERN
ERA AND RECOGNIZED THAT THIS IS
A CITY THAT HAS TO WORK FOR
EVERYONE AND THAT EVERYONE NEEDS
TO BE PART OF THE PROCESS. AND,
MR. MAYOR, MR. SPEAKER, WHATEVER
WE'LL CALL YOU TODAY, I ALSO,
JUST AS A GAY MAN, WANT TO THANK
YOU FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART
THAT IN THE 1970S, WHEN IT WAS
NOT POPULAR TO DO SO, YOU
DECRIMINALIZED, BEING LGBTQ IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, IT
DIDN'T TAKE THE US SUPREME COURT
STRIKING DOWN THAT LAW. YOU GOT
RID OF THAT LAW BEFORE IT WAS
POPULAR, BEFORE PEOPLE WERE
CHEERING YOU ON FOR THAT BECAUSE
YOU KNEW IT WAS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO. AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
ON BEHALF OF MY COMMUNITY. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
WIENER. THE FLOOR IS TO SENATOR
UMBERG. SENATOR UMBERG. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
COLLEAGUES, IS THE ONLY MEMBER
OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT ACTUALLY
HAS LIVED EXPERIENCE WITH
SPEAKER BROWN, I HAVE MANY
STORIES TO TELL, BUT I WILL
RESTRICT MYSELF TO JUST A FEW.
BY THE WAY, I THOUGHT IT'S
INTERESTING THAT MR. REYES, MR.
CONDIT, ARE IN THE GALLERY. I
THOUGHT YOU GUYS HAD KISSED AND
MADE UP. MR. SPEAKER, THAT THEY
COME DOWN HERE AT SOME POINT.
THAT'S ANOTHER STORY FOR ANOTHER
DAY. SO. MR. SPEAKER, WAS WITH
MY APOLOGIES TO THE PARTY
EMERITUS AND THE CURRENT PARTY
AND THE OTHER LEADERS HERE WAS
THE MOST TALENTED ELECTED
OFFICIAL I HAD EVER SERVED WITH
IN ALL WAYS POLITICALLY,
LEGISLATIVELY, POLICY WISE. AND
HE IS METICULOUS AND EVERYTHING
HE DOES, YOU CAN TELL BY THE WAY
HE DRESSES, HE'S METICULOUS.
HE'S HE IS A PROFESSIONAL IN
EVERYTHING HE DOES. AND BACK IN
THE DAY, WAY BACK IN THE DAY, AT
THE END OF THE SESSION, THERE
WAS AN END OF SESSION BASH WHERE
THE MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
PERFORMED. YOU MAY REMEMBER, MR.
SPEAKER, AND IT WAS AN
EXTRAVAGANZA THAT YOU BASICALLY
PRODUCED AND YOU ASSIGNED
DIFFERENT MEMBERS TO DO
DIFFERENT THINGS, AND YOU ASSIGN
ME IN TO BE IN A DANCE ROUTINE
WITH FOUR AFRICAN AMERICAN
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY, WHICH
WAS SORT OF HUMOROUS, JUST TO
IMAGINE THAT. AND WE WERE IT'S
APPROPRIATE WE'RE DISCUSSING
THIS TODAY. WE WERE IN THE MIDST
OF A BUDGET CRISIS. WE WERE, I
THINK, TWO MONTHS OVERDUE ON THE
BUDGET, AND I WAS NOT SUPPORTIVE
OF THE BUDGET. AND AT ONE POINT,
MY STAFF GOT A CALL AND SAID,
THE SPEAKER WANTS TO SEE YOU.
AND I THOUGHT, OKAY, THIS IS THE
MEETING. THIS IS THE MEETING,
AND I'M GOING TO I DON'T KNOW
WHERE I'M GOING TO GO, BUT I'M
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO COME BACK
TO MY OFFICE ANYWAY. SO I GO
DOWN TO THE MEETING AND AGAIN,
HE'S PUTTING TOGETHER THE END OF
SESSION EXTRAVAGANZA, AND I GO
IN READY FOR THIS CONVERSATION.
THÀNH AND I COME IN AND THERE'S
TWO OF YOU THERE. YOU AND
ANOTHER FELLA, AND YOU SAY,
UMBERG, YOU DANCE LIKE YOU
DON'T. YOU'RE NOT A GOOD DANCER.
IT'S WHAT YOU SAID. KIND OF KIND
OF SAID THAT. AND I'VE GOT THIS
GUY HERE WHO'S GOING TO TEACH
YOU TO DANCE. SO WE'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE BUDGET CRISIS, AND
YOU HIRE SOMEBODY TO TEACH ME
HOW TO DANCE. NEVER WORKED,
NEVER QUITE WORKED. BUT YOU
WANTED TO BE A PROFESSIONAL IN
ALL YOU DID. AND I THANK YOU. WE
OWE SO MUCH AS CALIFORNIANS TO
YOU. I. WHEN I LEFT IN 1994, I
SAID, I WILL TELL MY
GRANDCHILDREN I SERVE WITH THE
GREAT WILLIE BROWN. I CAN DO
THAT TODAY. THANK YOU, MR.
SPEAKER. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, SENATOR UMBERG, GREAT
TO HEAR ABOUT YOUR DANCE MOVES,
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND UNLIKE THAT GREAT
STORY FROM MY COLLEAGUE, MR.
UMBERG, I DID NOT HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF SERVING WITH THE
GREAT WILLIE BROWN, BUT I DID
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO READ
BASIC BROWN. AND I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU, NOT JUST FOR MEETING
WITH NEW MEMBERS AND FRESHMAN
MEMBERS WHO ARE PART OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS, BUT
ACTUALLY WRITING DOWN YOUR
THOUGHTS, YOUR STRATEGIES, YOUR
LIVED EXPERIENCES THAT HAVE
HELPED TO TEACH US HOW TO
UNDERSTAND THIS PLACE. THAT IS
PART OF THE LEGACY THAT I WILL
TAKE WITH ME ALONG WITH MY AUNTS
AND UNCLES WHO HAVE A PICTURE OF
DOCTOR KING AND A PICTURE OF
WILLIE BROWN ON THEIR WALL.
BECAUSE YOU REPRESENTED
LEADERSHIP AND THAT BLACK
LEADERS COULD LEAD ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT IS THE MODEL
THAT WE FOLLOW TODAY. THOSE ARE
THE FOOTSTEPS THAT WE ARE TRYING
TO FILL. AND I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LIFE'S COMMITMENT
TO THIS GREAT STATE AND MAKING
YOURSELF AVAILABLE TO ALL OF US
TO LEARN THE LESSONS OF HOW TO
LEAD THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. BROWN. MEMBERS AND GUESTS,
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WISHING A
GREAT HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO THE ONE
AND ONLY SPEAKER, MAYOR WILLIE
BROWN. YOU NEED IT.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO RETURN
TO SENATE. THIRD READING. BUT IF
YOU'D LIKE TO GET A PHOTOGRAPH,
WE'D LIKE TO INVITE YOU TO THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER, TO TAKE AN
INDIVIDUAL PICTURE. BUT WE DO
WANT TO MOVE FORWARD WITH OUR
BUSINESS THIS AFTERNOON.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO
FILE ITEM 46 BY SENATOR DODD.
WE'RE MOVED TO FILE ITEM 46 BY
SENATOR DODD. THIS IS SCR 160.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 160 BY
SENATOR DODD. RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA WINE MONTH. SENATOR
DODD, PLEASE GIVE SENATOR DODD
HIS ATTENTION. MR. PRESIDENT
MEMBERS, I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
SCR 160, WHICH RECOGNIZES
SEPTEMBER 2020 FOR AS CALIFORNIA
WINE MONTH SINCE EVER SINCE EVEN
BEFORE THE FOUNDING OF THE
GOLDEN STATE, THERE'S BEEN A
STRONG VITICULTURE TRADITION IN
CALIFORNIA. THE OLDEST
COMMERCIAL WINERY IN OUR STATE,
BUENA VISTA WINERY, WAS FOUNDED
IN 1857. IT STILL STANDS IN MY
DISTRICT, AND THEY STILL PRODUCE
OUTSTANDING VINTAGES. OUR STATE
IS HOME TO OVER 6000 BONDED
WINERIES. WINE GRAPES ARE GROWN
IN 49 OF OUR COUNTIES AND
CALIFORNIA WINE ACCOUNTS FOR 95%
OF THE UNITED STATES WINE
EXPORTS. THESE STATISTICS
DEMONSTRATE OUR UNIQUE TERROIR
AND THE HUGE SCALE OF THE HOME
GROWN INDUSTRY. AND WHILE I'M
PROUD TO REPRESENT THE WORLD
CLASS WINE REGIONS OF NAPA AND
SONOMA, HOME, OF COURSE, TO SOME
OF THE WORLD'S FINEST WINES, I'M
GLAD TO BE JOINED BY COAUTHORS
FROM ALL OVER THIS GREAT STATE.
WE'RE FORTUNATE TO HAVE SO MANY
EMERGING EMERGING WINE REGIONS,
RANGING FROM THE SIERRA
FOOTHILLS TO THE VALLEY DOWN TO
SANTA BARBARA, DOWN TO SAN
DIEGO. LET'S RAISE A GLASS AND
DESIGNATE SEPTEMBER 2024 AS
CALIFORNIA'S WINE MONTH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE,
SENATOR DODD. THANK YOU FOR THAT
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
RESOLUTION ON THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLLCALL. SEEING
NO OBJECTION IN AYES 38. NO
ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM 48. THIS IS SCR 162 BY
SENATOR ALLEN. SENATOR LIMÓN IS
PRESENTING. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 162 BY SENATOR ALLEN.
RELATIVE TO ALZHEIMER'S AND
BRAIN AWARENESS MONTH AND THE
LONGEST DAY. SENATOR LEVIN THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, ON
BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA MONICA, I RISE TO PRESENT
SCR 162 RECOGNIZING THE MONTH OF
JUNE AS ALZHEIMER'S AND BRAIN
AWARENESS MONTH AND JUNE 20TH AS
THE LONGEST DAY. COUNTLESS
CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR LOVED
ONES ARE IMPACTED BY ALZHEIMER'S
AND OTHER NEUROLOGICAL
CONDITIONS EACH DAY, AND THE
TOLL THEY TAKE ON OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR ECONOMY IS
INCALCULABLE. AS THE DAY OF THE
YEAR, WITH THE MOST SUNLIGHT,
THE LONGEST DAY IS A FITTING
REBUTTAL TO THE PROGRESSIVE
DARKNESS OF NEURODEGENERATIVE
DISEASES AND USES OF SHARED
EXPERIENCES OF THE SOLSTICE. AS
THE BASIS FOR VOLUNTEERING AND
AWARENESS FOR ALZHEIMER'S. AFTER
OVER A CENTURY OF RESEARCH SINCE
THE IDENTIFICATION OF
ALZHEIMER'S, THE CAUSES OF THE
DISEASE ARE STILL NOT FULLY
UNDERSTOOD. HOWEVER, MAJOR
BREAKTHROUGHS IN TREATMENT AND
EARLY DETECTION ARE BEING MADE
POSSIBLE BY ADVANCEMENTS IN
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS BRAIN
MAPPING, CONTINUED AND INCREASED
INVESTMENT IN CUTTING EDGE
TREATMENTS AND PHARMACEUTICALS,
AS WELL AS HEIGHTENED RESEARCH
INTO EARLY DETECTION IS CRUCIAL
FOR EXTENDING AND PRESERVING
LIFE EXPECTANCY. RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN THAT BIOMARKER PRESENTS IN
THE BRAIN 20 YEARS BEFORE THE
ONSET OF ALZHEIMER'S SYMPTOMS,
AND THEY OFFER A CRUCIAL
OPPORTUNITY TO IDENTIFY PATIENTS
YEARS EARLY AND TAKE STEPS TO
DELAY AND MITIGATE THE ONSET OF
SYMPTOMS. CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE A HUB
FOR RESEARCH AND INNOVATION AT
THE CENTER OF TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCEMENTS, WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE HUGE STRIDES
IN DIAGNOSING AND TREATING THESE
CONDITIONS THE LONGEST STAY
SERVES AS AN IMPORTANT REMINDER
OF THE CHALLENGES FACED BY
PATIENTS, CAREGIVERS, AND
FAMILIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND
THE NEED FOR ONGOING ATTENTION
ON THIS OFTEN UNSEEN CONDITION
IN THE FACE OF A DISEASE THAT IS
SO ISOLATING FOR THOSE
SUFFERING. OUR COMMUNITIES
DESERVE THE SUPPORT, ATTENTION,
AND LONG TERM COMMITMENT OF THE
STATE AS WE WORK TOWARDS A CURE.
MEMBERS IN RECOGNITION OF
ALZHEIMER'S AND BRAIN AWARENESS
MONTH AND IN APPRECIATION OF THE
AWARENESS, EFFORTS OF THE
LONGEST DAY, I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON SCR 162. THANK YOU,
SENATOR LIMÓN. I SEE MICROPHONES
UP FROM SENATOR GROVE AND
SENATOR NEWMAN. SENATOR Þ
MICROPHONES DOWN. SENATOR NEWMAN
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. MY WIFE SERVES ON THE
BOARD OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION OF ORANGE COUNTY,
LARGELY OUT OF HER EXPERIENCE
HAVING LOST HER MOM TO
ALZHEIMER'S. THIS IS A TERRIBLE
DISEASE THAT STEALS LOVED ONES
FROM THEIR FAMILIES WELL BEFORE
IT ACTUALLY TAKES THEIR LIVES.
AND I COMMEND ALL OF THE GOOD
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING SO HARD
TO FIND A CURE. AND IN THE
ABSENCE OF A CURE, TREATMENTS
FOR THE DISEASE, AS WELL AS
PROVIDING SUPPORT FOR THE LOVED
ONES AFFECTED BY IT. AND I ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR NEWMAN. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE? ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE.
SENATOR LIMÓN, YOU MAY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 38 NOES ZERO.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NOW. BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING.
THIS IS FILE ITEM 120. ACR 140
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS.
SENATOR GONZALEZ IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 140 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS RELATIVE
TO CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
DAY AND THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN
CULTURAL AWARENESS CONFERENCE.
SENATOR GONZALEZ, THANK YOU. I
RISE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS TO PRESENT ACR 140,
WHICH RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE
OF CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
DAY, WHICH IS CELEBRATED EVERY
YEAR ON THE FOURTH FRIDAY OF
SEPTEMBER. IN JUNE 2019,
GOVERNOR NEWSOM ISSUED AN
APOLOGY TO THE STATE'S
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES AND CONDEMNED THE
GENOCIDE AND HEINOUS ATROCITIES
OF CALIFORNIA'S PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS AND
LEGISLATURES. IN AN EFFORT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT HISTORY AND
CREATE FURTHER UNDERSTANDING,
THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN CULTURAL
AWARENESS CONFERENCE IS HELD
ANNUALLY ON THE SAME DAY AS THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN DAY
TO PROVIDE EDUCATORS WITH THE
RESOURCES TO TEACH THE HISTORY
OF CALIFORNIA'S TRIBES, ALONG
WITH THEIR RICH AND DIVERSE
CULTURES, CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN BLESSED WITH
ELDERS WHO, DESPITE MANY
OBSTACLES, HAVE WORKED TO
PRESERVE LANGUAGE, SONGS, AND
STEWARDSHIP OF NATURAL
RESOURCES. I ASK THAT YOU JOIN
ME IN RECOGNIZING CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN DAY BY VOTING
AYE ON ACR 140. THANK YOU,
SENATOR GONZALEZ. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS, ON THIS
RESOLUTION, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS. AYES 38. NO ZERO.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THERE IS ONE
ITEM ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES ANYONE WISH TO REMOVE THIS
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR?
THAT WOULD MAKE IT A NO CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALL RIGHT, SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ THE CONSENT CALENDAR
. SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION 15,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE VÌ.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER AYE. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES
LAIRD. AYE. LEMON. AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE MINH. AYE.
NEWMAN WHEN? AYE. NILO AYE.
OKUBO AYE. PADILLA PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE.
CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN.
BECKER AYE. DALLY. AYE JONES.
NEWMAN. AYE BETHEA. AYE ON A
VOTE OF 38 TO 0. FILE ITEM 140,
OUR ONLY ITEM ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. IT PASSES.
EXCUSE ME. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NOW. BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS, MEMBERS, UPON
RECEIPT OF SB 12 1524, PURSUANT
TO SENATE RULE 29.10 D, SB 1524
WILL BE REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
MEMBERS I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE
SENATOR ARCHULETA, FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR SKINNER, SENATOR
ARCHULETA, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THOSE MEMBERS OF THE
MILITARY AND VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE WILL MEET IN ROOM 2200
IMMEDIATELY AFTER SESSION. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ARCHULETA. SENATOR
SKINNER, EXCUSE ME, YES, I'M
ANNOUNCING THAT THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE WILL MEET AFTER THE
ADJOURNMENT OF BNP IN ROOM 2100.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SKINNER. I DO
BELIEVE, BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS HAS COMPLETED THEIR
BUSINESS. ALL RIGHT. ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR BRADFORD, THE SENATE
ENERGY AND UTILITIES COMMITTEE
WILL MEET IN ROOM 1200.
FOLLOWING THE ADJOURNMENT OF OUR
SESSION HERE. THEN, SENATOR
SKINNER, THEN WE WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION. HOUSING
IN ROOM 2100. THANK YOU, SENATOR
SKINNER. ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO NOW MOVE TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS IS A
TIME FOR ADJOURN IN MEMORIES.
I'D LIKE TO ASK SENATORS TO
RETURN TO THEIR THEIR DESKS.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH SENATOR EGGMAN.
SENATOR EGGMAN, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS,
THANK YOU FOR PAYING ATTENTION.
WE HAVE FAMILY UP IN THE, IN THE
GALLERY, TODAY I'D LIKE TO DO AN
ADJOURN IN MEMORY AND A
RECOGNITION OF A HERO. AT THE
SAME TIME, I'M DOING AN ADJOURN
IN MEMORY TODAY, AND HIS FAMILY
IS WITH US IN THE CHAMBER. 15
YEAR OLD XAVIER ANTHONY MARTINEZ
WAS BORN DECEMBER 12TH, 2008, IN
STOCKTON, CALIFORNIA, TO PETE
AND AMANDA MARTINEZ, WHO ARE
HERE WITH US TODAY. AMANDA IS
HERE WITH US. XAVIER IS ONE OF
THOSE KIDS WHO JUST WANTED
EVERYBODY TO BE HAPPY AND TO GET
ALONG, AND HE LOVED TO BRIGHTEN
PEOPLE'S DAY WITH HIS SILLINESS
AND LAUGHTER. HE LOVED ANIMALS.
HE LOVED NATURE. HE SPENT HIS
CHILDHOOD DAYS PLAYING OUTSIDE
AFTER SCHOOL AND GATHERING
FLOWERS FOR HIS MOM, AMANDA. AND
AS A TEENAGER, HE WAS ALL ABOUT
VIDEO GAMES AND OUTDOOR
ADVENTURES. HE LIKED RIDING
BIKES, CAMPING, SWIMMING AND
FISHING. HE LOVED AMUSEMENT
PARKS AND RIDING THE HIGH THRILL
RIDES, AND FELT MOST ALIVE WHEN
THERE WAS HAPPINESS AND FAMILY
AROUND HIM. XAVIER TOUCHED THE
LIVES OF MANY WITH HIS
GENEROSITY AND COMPASSION, AND
HE DEMONSTRATED HIS MATURITY AND
STRENGTH DURING THE FAMILIES
TENUOUS, TENUOUS TIME WITH HIS
DAD'S ILLNESS. AND WE WISH THEM
NOW AS THEY APPROACH THAT
CHAPTER. ON MARCH 13TH, XAVIER
WENT MISSING AFTER AN INCIDENT
AT HIS HIGH SCHOOL AND WAS LAST
SEEN ENTERING THE NEARBY LEVEE
THAT IS PART OF OUR CALAVERAS
RIVER. AND DESPITE THE EFFORTS
OF SCHOOL PERSONNEL AND LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT, XAVIER WAS
UNABLE TO EMERGE FROM THE MURKY
WATERS. LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND PERSONNEL SEARCHED FOR
ALMOST A WEEK AND WERE UNABLE TO
LOCATE HIS BODY. WITH HIS FAMILY
ON THE LEVEE BANK WAITING A FEW
DAYS INTO THAT, WE HAVE OUR
LOCAL HERE, JUAN MARIA, WHO WAS
A PROFESSIONAL DIVER AND WITH
HIS FAMILY STANDING, ALSO ON THE
BANK, HE WENT IN AND FELT THAT
IT WAS HIS DUTY TO GO IN AND TO
RECOVER THAT YOUNG BOY IF HE
COULD. SO TODAY, I, ALONG WITH
AMANDA AND HER FAMILY, WISH TO
THANK MR. JUAN MARIA AND HIS
WIFE MERCEDES, FOR THEIR HEROIC
AND COMPASSIONATE ASSISTANCE IN
THE SEARCH FOR XAVIER AND
BRINGING A SENSE OF CLOSURE TO
HIS BEREAVED FAMILY. I'LL ALSO
ADD, SINCE THAT TIME IN MARCH,
HE HAS RECOVERED ANOTHER 5 OR 6
BODIES FROM OUR LOCAL RIVERS,
THOUGH HE WAS TAKEN TOO SOON
FROM HIS FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
XAVIER'S LEGACY OF LOVE AND
WARMTH WILL LIVE ON IN THE
HEARTS OF THOSE WHO ARE LUCKY
ENOUGH TO KNOW HIM. WE ARE
JOINED TODAY AGAIN BY HIS
PARENTS AND THEIR CHILDREN AND
HIS LOVING FAMILIES, AND WE WISH
THAT YOU ACCEPT THE SENATE'S
ADJOURNMENT AND HIS MEMORY, AND
MAY HIS MEMORY BE A BLESSING. SO
IF WE COULD PLEASE MEMORIALIZE
HIM. THANK YOU, SENATOR EGGMAN.
TO THE FRIENDS AND FAMILY OF
XAVIER MARTINEZ. THE SENATE
EXTENDS THEIR CONDOLENCES.
SENATOR EGGMAN, PLEASE BRING HIS
NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
SENATE JOURNAL, AND THAT WE MAY
ADJOURN IN HIS BLESSED MEMORY.
WE WOULD LIKE TO NOW RECOGNIZE
SENATOR OCHOA BOGH. MR.
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS, TODAY I
RISE TO ASK THE SENATE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A LONG TIME
LEGISLATIVE STAFFER, A
COLLEAGUE, AND MOST IMPORTANTLY,
MY FRIEND, ART WELCH, BORN IN
MISSOURI IN DECEMBER OF 1937.
ART WAS A KIND AND LOVING MAN
WHO ALWAYS HAD A SMILE AND A
STORY VÆ. IN 1960, HE GRADUATED
FROM THE SOUTHEAST MISSOURI
STATE WITH A DEGREE IN MARKETING
AND BUSINESS MANAGEMENT, AND
MOVED TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO
BEGIN HIS CAREER, RETIRING IN
1996. ART KEPT HIMSELF BUSY
DURING HIS SO-CALLED RETIREMENT
YEARS. HE SERVED ON THE BANNING
CITY COUNCIL FOR 12 YEARS, AND
AS THE MAYOR OF BANNING FOR FOUR
YEARS. HIS COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC
SERVICE EXTENDED TO HIS ROLES
WITH THE RIVERSIDE TRANSIT
AGENCY AND AS A FIELD
REPRESENTATIVE FOR ASSEMBLYMAN
PAUL COOK AND SENATORS BILL
EMERSON AND MIKE MORRELL FOR THE
LAST THREE, AND A HALF YEARS. HE
WAS A VALUED MEMBER OF MY
DISTRICT STAFF. ART WAS AN
INTEGRAL PART OF OUR OFFICE. HE
LIVED A LIFE OF SERVICE AND
DEDICATION TO HIS FAMILY,
COMMUNITY AND CHURCH. HIS
EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE WERE
AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
TREMENDOUS GIFT TO US ALL. I'M
THANKFUL FOR HIS EXCEPTIONAL
INTEGRITY, HIS WORK ETHIC,
DEDICATION AND GENEROSITY TO HIS
FAMILY AND OUR ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
HE WAS A TIRELESS ADVOCATE FOR
IMPROVING THE LIVES OF OTHERS.
ART WAS A PILLAR OF HIS
COMMUNITY AND THROUGH THE YEARS
WAS REGULARLY RECOGNIZED FOR
LEADERSHIP ROLES IN MANY
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS,
INCLUDING TABLE OF PLENTY, THE
BEAUMONT PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH,
AND THE SAN GORGONIO PASS
ROTARY. HE NOT ONLY SUPPORTED
HIS COMMUNITY IN THE BIG
MOMENTS, BUT ALSO IN SMALL ONES,
GIVING A CANE TO SOMEONE WHO
NEEDED IT, WATCHING THE CHILD OF
FRIENDS WHILE THEY ENJOYED THEIR
FIRST VACATION TOGETHER, OR
SIMPLY MAKING HIS ROUNDS THROUGH
THE COMMUNITY, OFFERING A
COMPASSIONATE EAR OR A SHOULDER
TO LEAN ON, HE WAS ALWAYS THERE,
AND HE DID IT WITHOUT
PUBLICIZING IT, KEEPING IT
BETWEEN HIM, THEM, AND GOD. HE
WAS A TRUE SERVANT TO HIS
COMMUNITY. WHEN HE WASN'T
WORKING OR VOLUNTEERING. ART
ENJOYS SPENDING TIME WITH JODY,
HIS WIFE OF MORE THAN 63 YEARS.
CHILDREN, LIZBETH, JIM AND
SCOTT, THEIR SPOUSES, HIS SEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN, AND HIS THREE
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. ART WAS A
HANDS ON FATHER AND GRANDFATHER.
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS, HE COACHED
POP WARNER, FOOTBALL, SOCCER,
SOCCER, BALL, AND BASEBALL.
ALWAYS FOCUSED ON HIS KIDS AND
GRANDKIDS AND SUPPORTIVE OF
THEIR INDIVIDUAL INTEREST IN HIS
CHILDREN'S WORDS, HE WAS ALWAYS
THERE REGARDLESS IF THEY WON OR
LOST A GAME. HE WAS THERE TO
BUILD THEM UP AND SUPPORT THEM.
I THANK HIS FAMILY FOR SHARING
HIS TIME WITH US AND THE
OPPORTUNITY IT GAVE US TO
EXPERIENCE ART'S KINDNESS,
FRIENDSHIP AND THE INSTITUTIONAL
KNOWLEDGE HE BROUGHT TO OUR
OFFICE. I WAS ABSOLUTELY BLESSED
TO HAVE ART A COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION AS PART OF MY TEAM. I
WAS HIS DANCING PARTNER AS HE
OFTEN WOULD SHARE WITH FOLKS.
ONCE AT AN EVENT, THE BAND WAS
PLAYING MY FAVORITE GLENN MILLER
SONG, A STRING OF PEARLS.
COULDN'T STAY IN MY SEAT AND I
ASKED HIM, ART, WOULD YOU DANCE
WITH ME? AND TO MY DELIGHT, HE
DID SO. AND EVER SINCE THEN I
WAS REFERRED TO AS HIS DANCING
PARTNER. HE WAS LOVED BY MANY
WHO KNEW HIM. I WOULD BE HONORED
IF THIS BODY WOULD ADJOURN IN
HIS MEMORY OF ONE OF OUR OWN,
ARTHUR WELCH. THANK YOU, SENATOR
OCHOA. BOGH. THE SENATE EXTENDS
ITS CONDOLENCES TO THE MANY
FRIENDS AND FAMILY OF OUR FORMER
SENATE STAFFER, ART WELCH. AND
AT YOUR REQUEST, THE SENATE WILL
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. WE'RE
GOING TO TURN NEXT TO SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY WITH GREAT SORROW TO ASK
THAT THE SENATE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF GINA LA DIVINA, WHO
PASSED AWAY UNEXPECTEDLY ON
WEDNESDAY, JUNE 5TH, FOR MORE
THAN 20 YEARS, GINA WAS A
BELOVED FIXTURE IN SAN
FRANCISCO'S DRAG COMMUNITY,
GRACING STAGES OF SOME OF OUR
MOST ICONIC VENUES, INCLUDING
AUNT CHARLIE'S THE STUD, OASIS
AND OTHERS. HER PERFORMANCE IS
PARTICULARLY HER RENDITIONS OF
SHIRLEY BASSEY'S CLASSICS,
CAPTIVATED AUDIENCES WITH GLAMOR
AND INTENTIONALITY AND LEFT AN
INDELIBLE MARK ON OUR COMMUNITY.
SOME OF GINA'S SIGNATURE SHOWS
INCLUDED HER ONE WOMAN SHOWS AND
THE POPULAR HOT BOX GIRLS. BORN
IN WILLIAMSPORT, PENNSYLVANIA IN
1949, SHE MOVED TO SANTA ROSA IN
1967 TO ATTEND BEAUTY SCHOOL.
THE SAME YEAR THAT SHE
TRANSITIONED. GINA HAILED FROM
SANTA ROSA TO SAN FRANCISCO IN
1975, AND SPENT MUCH OF HER
ILLUSTRIOUS CAREER PERFORMING IN
SAN FRANCISCO'S VIBRANT
NIGHTLIFE VENUES. SHE WAS ALSO
KNOWN FOR HER STORYTELLING AND
HER GENEROUS SPIRIT, OFTEN
HANDING COSTUMES OFF TO OTHER
PERFORMERS TO ENCOURAGE AND
SUPPORT THEIR CAREERS. SHE
ALWAYS HELPED BRING OTHER PEOPLE
UP. GINA WAS A PASSIONATE
ADVOCATE FOR IMPORTANT CAUSES.
SHE PERFORMED AT BENEFITS FOR
MARRIAGE EQUALITY IN CALIFORNIA
AND HER ADVOCACY AND
PERFORMANCES DEMONSTRATED HER
COMMITMENT TO EQUALITY AND
JUSTICE WITHIN AND FOR THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY. SAN FRANCISCO DRAG
LAUREATE D'ARCY DROLLINGER
DESCRIBES GINA AS A QUOTE
UNQUOTE SHOWGIRL, A HAIR
GODDESS, A MENTOR AND A MUSE,
DARCY HIGHLIGHTS GINA'S
INFLUENCE AND DEEP CONNECTIONS
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY. SHE WENT
ON, QUOTE, UNAPOLOGETICALLY
HERSELF, GINA CHARTED HER OWN
PATH, DISPLAYING FIERCE LOYALTY
AND DEDICATION TO HER CHOSEN
FAMILY. UP UNTIL THE VERY END.
GINA LA DIVINA WILL BE
REMEMBERED AS A TRUE PIONEER, AN
EXCEPTIONAL PERFORMER, AND A
STEADFAST ADVOCATE WHO MADE THE
WORLD A BRIGHTER AND MORE
INCLUSIVE PLACE. GINA'S IMPACT
ON THE DRAG COMMUNITY AND THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY MORE BROADLY IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE WORLD,
PARTICULARLY DURING THESE
DIFFICULT TIMES FOR OUR
COMMUNITY, IS IMMEASURABLE. HER
ARTISTRY BROUGHT JOY AND
INSPIRATION TO COUNTLESS PEOPLE,
AND HER ADVOCACY HELPED PAVE THE
WAY FOR GREATER ACCEPTANCE AND
EQUALITY. COLLEAGUES, I ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN THE SENATE IN MEMORY
OF GINA LA DIVINA, A TRULY
EXCEPTIONAL HUMAN BEING. THANK
YOU, SENATOR WIENER. THE SENATE
EXTENDS ITS CONDOLENCES TO THE
FRIENDS AND FAMILY OF GINA LA
DIVINA. PLEASE BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED IN THE SENATE
JOURNAL AS WE ADJOURN. IN HER
MEMORY. IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS BEFORE THE SENATE.
SENATOR MCGUIRE. THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, JUST A
REMINDER. WE'LL BE IN SESSION
THIS COMING WEDNESDAY, THIS
COMING WEDNESDAY EVENING FOR
BUDGET VOTES. SO THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
WEDNESDAY, JUNE 26TH AT 6 P.M.
THANK YOU. SO MUCH. THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL 3:30
P.M, AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE ON WEDNESDAY,
JUNE 26TH AT 6 P.M.